hemos trabajado en una descripción
intuitiva de la respuesta natural de un
circuito lc en el vídeo anterior
configuramos todo y ahora estamos listos
para cerrar el interruptor cerramos el
interruptor nuestro tiempo es igual a 0
y ahora que sucede pues tenemos cierto
voltaje de 0 en el capacitor lo que
significa que ahora tendremos un voltaje
en nuestro inductor así que de pronto al
cerrar el interruptor nuestro inductor
se encuentra con que tiene cierto
voltaje que está pasando a través de él
veamos esta ecuación de aquí del
inductor y nos dice que debe 0 que es
nuestro voltaje inicial que viene del
capacitor es l por la pendiente de la
corriente ahora tenemos un voltaje
finito y tenemos un valor finito en l lo
que significa que del dt es un valor es
un número y si ponemos una carga
positiva aquí sabremos que de 0 es
positivo vamos a graficar esto vamos a
graficar lo que está sucediendo aquí
ponemos nuestros ejes aquí tenemos a t y
aquí ahí y en esta misma gráfica vamos a
poner tanto ahí como ave en diferente
color
la corriente estará en azul y el voltaje
en anaranjado y aquí tenemos nuestro eje
del tiempo cuál será el voltaje cuando
comenzamos pues nuestro voltaje era de 0
justo antes de que cerramos el
interruptor así que lo ponemos aquí y
cuál era la corriente cuando iniciamos
pues era igual a cero así que también la
ponemos aquí ahora vamos a graficar lo
que creemos que pasa justo cuando
cerramos el interruptor sabemos que va a
haber cierta dt que es igual a b 0 / l
lo grafica mos y vemos que va a haber
una pendiente que se va a elevar una
pendiente positiva de la corriente ya
dimos nuestro primer paso y ahora la
otra cosa que está ocurriendo aquí es lo
que está haciendo q que está haciendo
vamos a rastrear nuestra carga q va a
comenzar a fluir afuera de éste
va a ser la corriente de la que hablamos
de y de t es una corriente finita y esta
corriente está provocada por la carga
que se encuentra en el capacitor por lo
que la corriente comienza a fluir en el
circuito y va a llegar a la placa de
abajo del capacitor lo que significa que
la cantidad de carga que se encuentra en
la placa superior va a disminuir lo que
significa que el voltaje también va a
disminuir vamos a graficar el voltaje el
voltaje va a comenzar a disminuir porque
la carga está saliendo del capacitor muy
bien ahora sigamos graficando
alternadamente la corriente y el voltaje
para ver cómo están cambiando estos y lo
hacemos
analizando las ecuaciones que tenemos
ahora el voltaje en el inductor ya no es
de 0 va a hacer algún otro voltaje así
que del dt va a ser igual a b cualquiera
que ésta sea entre él y notamos que ve
disminuyó un poco lo que significa que
la pendiente de la corriente también
disminuye
un poco así que dibujamos una versión un
poco más plana de la pendiente de la
corriente y ahora que le va a ocurrir al
voltaje pues más carga ha salido del
capacitor y se ha dirigido hacia la
placa opuesta por lo que el voltaje va a
seguir disminuyendo así que vamos a
seguir viendo qué pasa el momento a
momento conforme pasa el tiempo cada vez
que baja el voltaje la pendiente de la
corriente se va a ser un poco más plana
y el voltaje sigue bajando ya que la
carga está saliendo del capacitor y
eventualmente ese voltaje va a llegar a
cero y en el punto en el que el voltaje
es igual a cero la pendiente de la
corriente va a ser cero así que justo
cuando esto sucede la pendiente de la
corriente es cero ahora el valor de la
corriente es un número así que ahora
tenemos cierto valor en la corriente y
cero voltaje y qué sucede cuando tenemos
cero voltaje veamos aquí cuando este
valor del voltaje es cero significa que
la carga es cero lo que significa que la
carga en ambos lados del capacitor está
equilibrada
la cantidad de carga existe en la parte
de arriba y en la parte de abajo del
capacitor y qué va a pasar después el
voltaje sigue en 0 va a subir va a bajar
que va a pasar que va a ser la corriente
vamos a verlo aquí tenemos una corriente
finita lo que significa que la corriente
sigue fluyendo pero en qué dirección
pues en esta dirección de acá así y lo
que va a suceder ahora es que vamos a
tener un exceso de cargas positivas en
la parte de abajo del capacitor lo que
significa que la carga en el capacitor
va a ir aumentando pero en el sentido
opuesto por lo que el voltaje va a tener
el sentido opuesto también y esto nos
indica que vamos a tener un voltaje
negativo comenzará a aumentar por acá
abajo tengo un voltaje negativo y ahora
veo mi ecuación del inductor este valor
debe a que ahora es negativo lo que
significa que esta ley de t
ahora es una pendiente negativa y la
pendiente negativa luce como si fuera
yendo hacia
bajo y vamos a tener un poco menos de
corriente lo que significa que tendremos
una menor pendiente en el voltaje esta
corriente positiva va a seguir
entregando carga a la placa de abajo del
capacitor y eventualmente esta corriente
llegará a cero también y si vemos esta
situación estamos como empezamos tenemos
cero corriente y un voltaje negativo así
que es casi como empezamos comenzamos
con un voltaje alto positivo pero ahora
tenemos un voltaje negativo este voltaje
de aquí es menos de cero y esto es
porque toda la carga que estaba en la
planta superior del capacitor ha viajado
y llegado a la placa de abajo por lo que
tenemos la situación completamente al
revés de como iniciamos y debido a esta
asimetría no vamos a alargar este vídeo
por lo que vamos a continuar dibujando
esto repitiendo la situación el voltaje
va a regresar y la corriente hará esto
repetimos lo mismo que hicimos al inicio
cuando la curva estaba aquí
solo que con el signo del voltaje
invertido ahora llegamos a otra etapa
donde tenemos 0 volts y tenemos una
corriente negativa y vemos que
duplicamos la situación de acá solo que
con el signo opuesto en la corriente
tenemos una corriente positiva y aquí un
voltaje de 0 y ahora tenemos voltaje 0
pero una corriente negativa así que lo
que vimos que ocurrió aquí ocurrirá acá
pero al revés esta carga va a cambiar su
dirección vamos a quitar nuestras
flechas y ahora la carga que tenemos va
a comenzar a ir en este otro sentido
esta carga positiva que teníamos va a
comenzar a fluir así y se va a encontrar
con la carga negativa que tenemos de
este otro lado y esto es lo que está
ocurriendo en esta parte del ciclo y va
a continuar con el mismo comportamiento
tanto el voltaje como la corriente y
ahora si llegamos al mismo punto en el
que iniciamos ya replicamos nuestro
estado inicial y qué va a pasar después
va a ocurrir lo mismo que sucedió al
principio y esto se va a repetir tanto
para el voltaje como para la corriente
todo el tiempo que nosotros lo
permitamos en el circuito así que vamos
a tener un movimiento oscilatorio para
la corriente y también tendremos un
movimiento oscilatorio para el voltaje
conforme estos elementos que almacenan
energía cambian la carga almacenada por
energía en el campo magnético de regreso
a la carga almacenada y regresa así una
y otra vez así que esta es nuestra
explicación intuitiva de lo que ocurre
en un circuito lc cuando dejamos que
haga su respuesta natural tendrá este
movimiento oscilatorio de corriente en
el siguiente vídeo veremos cómo resulta
esto matemáticamente